orgasme
point culminant et terme de l'excitation
sexuelle caractérisée par des sensations
physiques intenses
c'est un peu court on va essayer de voir
s'il développe et quand même mais avant
de commencer une petite chose cette
vidéo est sponsorisé par les lots une
marque de sex-toys haut de gamme parce
qu'on ne devine pas avec l'orgasme alors
haut de gamme ça veut dire que les
objets sont fabriqués dans des matériaux
de qualité qui respecte les choix et les
muqueuses joli ça peut même servir de
déco la seule chez moi par exemple
solide et efficace
on croit qu'on se comprend testé et
approuvé par la rédaction de
dtcc c'est-à-dire mois essentiellement
leur philosophie chez les los et que le
bien être sexuel c'est une partie du
bien-être tout court et vous allez voir
dans cette vidéo que oui clairement
c'est le cas donc il propose tout un tas
de produits qu'on peut assimiler à une
gamme de soins personnels du coup comme
celui ci qui est à destination des gens
qui possèdent un clitoris ou celui là
qui est orienté pénis non ça n'est pas
une enceinte connectés peut-être que
pour le prochain modèle jeu mais on peut
leur proposer
et celui là qui est multifonction donc
il y en a pour tout le monde et oui
parce que si j'ai choisi de vous montrer
ces trois là c'est parce qu'ils collent
bien à l'esprit de la vidéo il n'y a pas
un orgasme il ya des orgasmes et autant
de façons de les obtenir que ce soit
tout seul ou à plusieurs en stimulant
telle ou telle partie de notre corps y
compris le cerveau au sens figuré 1
sinon ce dangereux donc je vous mets les
références de ces trois objets dans la
description de la vidéo et mon petit
cadeau pour toute commande passée sur le
site de lelo vous avez un tube de 75
mille litres de lubrifiant gratuit avec
le code
dtc dans tous les cas avec un peu
lubrifiants c'est toujours mieux aller
faire un tour sur leur site vous devriez
trouver votre bonheur ou au moins votre
plaisir mais revenons-en à nos moutons
c'est une façon de parler vu que la
définition du dictionnaire nous a un
petit peu laissé sur notre faim je vous
propose de gratter un petit peu pour
trouver deux ou trois autres trucs à
dire 1 et même beaucoup plus puisque
aujourd'hui on va parler de 14 trucs à
savoir sur l'orgasme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque minute dans le monde un million
et demi de personnes on engage depuis le
début de cette vidéo la totalité des
habitants de la région bourgogne franche
comté a eu un hangar
où les jours sur terre deux milliards et
demi de personnes ont un orgasme
selon l'association global dans le gard
depuis le générique j'ai déjà prononcé
quatre fois le mot orgasme 5 ça mérite
bien qu'on se marche un recul sur la
question un orgasme à quoi ça sert
pendant longtemps la théorie c'était que
l'unique but de l'orgasme c'était la
procréation parce qu'ils aboutissent est
à l'éjaculation donc à l'expulsion de
spermatozoïdes et qui provoquait des
contractions au niveau du vagin qui
facilite la progression des
spermatozoïdes en question sauf que
depuis on a un peu évolué et on s'est
rendu compte que non seulement c'est pas
complètement vrai mais en plus les
choses ont un peu changé depuis l'époque
où on vivait dans des grottes oui parce
que ça fait des millénaires maintenant
que l'objectif principal de la majorité
de nos rapports sexuels ça n'est plus
vraiment de perpétrer les frais sumène
d'ailleurs même notre corps ils
s'habituent aux changements de nos
moeurs et de nos habitudes de vie on dit
que la fonction crée l'organe par
exemple nos organes y se transforme au
fur et à mesure que l'usagé qu'on en a
se modifie il y en a qui disparaissent
ou qui s'atrophie y en a d'autres qui
prennent de l'ampleur y en a qui
changent de forme un exemple nos dents
elles ont évolué en même temps que notre
régime alimentaire et des chercheurs de
l'université de standford ont estimé en
2011 qu'à l'origine le pénis humain
était sans doute équipés de petits pics
comme beaucoup d'autres animaux mais qui
les a perdus au fur et à mesure que
l'être humain est devenu monogame et que
la durée de ces rapports sexuels s'est
allongée notre corps change donc parfois
même plus vite que les mentalités mais
bref à quoi ça sert un orgasme et ben en
2022 s'affairent à à prendre du plaisir
disons les choses comme elles sont et
par les temps qui courent on va pas
cracher sur un peu de bien-être mais
vous allez voir que c'est pas tout à
fait un orgasme comment ça marche un
orgasme c'est un phénomène complexe qui
met en jeu d'un côté des composantes
physiques à la fois mécanique chimique
et neurologiques mécanique parce qu'il
ya des trucs qui se gorgent de sang qui
groove qui change de forme chimique
parce que ça implique tout un tas de
substances sur lesquelles on va revenir
et neurologiques parce que tout ça est
déclenchée par la stimulation de tout un
tas de mer un peu partout mais pas
seulement parce qu'à pâques les nerfs
qui sont excités si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire il ya aussi une dimension
psychologique évidemment donc tout ça se
met en branle progressivement les
stimulations physiques et intellectuels
font gonfler tout ce qui doit gonfler ça
fait aussi afflué des hormones et des
neurotransmetteurs et une fois que tout
ça est bien mûre ça finit par déclencher
une série de contractions de muscles
notamment ceux du petit bassin c'est à
dire là dans le bas-ventre décontraction
plus ou moins nombreuses plus ou moins
puissantes rapide qui dure plus ou moins
longtemps etc mais on ne peut pas
réduire l'orgasme à une série de
contractions musculaires parce qu'encore
une fois il ya aussi les effets de
toutes les substances qu'on produit et
la dimension psychologique qui fait
qu'aucun orgasme ne ressemble
combien de temps ça dure un orgasme
alors déjà c'est assez compliqué d'avoir
accès aux records en la matière parce
que bon bah c'est assez rarement
pratiqué devant un huissier mais il ya
un épisode d'une émission américaine qui
s'appelle 500 me to be a littéralement
le sexe m'a envoyé aux urgences qui a
été consacré à une femme qui a dû être
hospitalisé après un orgasme qui avait
duré plus de trois heures c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup trop même on parle quand
même de muscles qui se contracte de
manière répétée c'est un coup à se
plaquer normalement un orgasme moyens ça
dure entre 3 et 20 secondes mais ça peut
monter jusqu'à 2 minutes ce qui est déjà
pas mal an c'est plus long que le thème
de james bond par exemple
l'orgasme est-ce que c'est open bar
alors open-bars pas vraiment mais le
schéma s'est pas non plus forcément un
orgasme et hop on plie les gaules les
orgasmes multiples ça existe pas
toujours et pas pour tout le monde mais
c'est possible
il ya quand même quelques freins qui
font que justement c'est pas possible
pour tout le monde il ya ce qu'on
appelle la période réfractaire d'abord
qui est ce temps plus ou moins long
après un orgasme roues le pénis se met
un petit peu en mode avion le temps de
recharger chez certaines personnes et
aussi des zones de la bulle qui sont
particulièrement sensibles après un
orgasme comme le tout au risque par
exemple et qui font que il vaut mieux
laisser reposer un petit peu ou au moins
à les explorer d'autres zones donc
parfois les orgasmes multiples c'est
possible d'autres fois c'est plus
compliqué mais disons que un c'est déjà
bien alors je ne vous parle pas des cas
particuliers comme les effets
secondaires de certains médicaments qui
peuvent déclencher des orgasmes
spontanées parfois même plusieurs
d'affilée ni du syndrome d'excitation
génitale persistant qui comme son nom
l'indiqué assez bien provoque des
sensations proches de leurs glaces ou
sans qu'ils aient aucune excitation
sexuelle je vous en parle pas là mais on
pourra en parler un séjour si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à me dire mais
bon le truc à retenir c'est que en
termes de nombre d'orgasmes comme de
durée entre chaque orgasme c'est comme
pour tout le reste finalement on est
toutes et tous un bon orgasme ça se
prépare
[Musique]
bonjour je suis philippe fcbe fait
aujourd'hui nous allons apprendre à
préparer un bon orgasme non non non
n'importe quoi virer moi ça y'a rien qui
va il n'y a pas de recette on a toutes
et tous des façons différentes d'arriver
à l'orgasme donc la première règle c'est
d'apprendre à connaître et la deuxième
c'est d'expliquer à ses partenaires
comment ça marche tout en en profitant
pour leur demander leur mode d'emploi
ensuite n'y a pas d'ingrédient à mettre
absolument dans la recette de l'orgasme
qui n'existe pas un plus mais il y en a
quand même un ou deux à éviter et vous
allez voir que pourtant on les retrouve
souvent la pénétration d'abord attention
me faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit
ça veut pas dire que c'est pas bien la
pénétration ça veut dire que ça n'est
pas le centre de tout on peut avoir un
rapport sexuel et un orgasme sans
pénétration évidemment et quand il y en
a une le rapport sexuel ça commence
avant et ça finit après pas délimité par
la pénétration ensuite les préliminaires
non par elle du calme écoutez bien
jusqu'au bout déjà appeler ça des
préliminaires ça sous-entend que c'est
un truc qui se passe avant le rapport
sexuel alors en fait ça en fait 100%
partie tout ce qui se passe avant la
pénétration éventuelles vous vous
souvenez c'est déjà le rapport sexuel en
duel et comme c'est pendant cette phase
que tous mais bien en place encore une
fois il n'ya pas de règle absolue mais
globalement plus on soigne le début
meyer et la fin et l'orgasme simultané
pour finir alors c'est très cool hein
mais ça reste quand même plus souvent
dans les films que dans la vraie vie ne
faut pas être déçu si ça arrive pas et
encore une fois il faut pas à partir du
principe qu'un rapport sexuel c'est
délimité par la pénétration au début et
l'orgasme de l'un des deux disons le
franchement plus souvent l'éjaculation à
la fin donc si l'un des partenaires a eu
un orgasme avant l'autre ça arrive très
souvent il fait en sorte que l'autre est
un orgasme aussi si l'autre en question
en a envie évidemment nous voilà on
cherche on découvre on s'adapte la
recette c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
recettes supérieures il ya mille façons
déclencher un langage alors oui je dis
mille c'est une façon de parler
évidemment mais quand même ce que je
veux dire c'est que les organes génitaux
non pas l'exclure sur l'organisme
évidemment stimuler le pénis stimuler le
clitoris de manière externe ou interne
c'est des valeurs sûres bien sûr le
point g quelques centimètres après
l'entrée du vagin bien sûr le dip spot
plus loin près du col de l'utérus ça
fonctionne bien aussi mais l'orgasme ma
mère par exemple ça existe aussi ma mère
en un mot pour désigner ce qui concerne
s1 l'orgasme annales pareil l'orgasme
prostatique aussi et le cerveau c'est
aussi une zone érogène attention là je
parle pas de ce qu'on appelle l'orgasme
cérébrale un conte déclenché avec des
sauts comme par exemple en faisant des
essais mais là je parle d'orgasme
sexuelles avec les contractions
musculaires dans le bas ventre et tout
déclenché avec des images mentales sans
aucune stimulation physique n'est pas
donné à tout le monde mais ça existe ça
a même été documentés scientifiquement
chez certaines personnes c'est la
douleur qui va déclencher un orgasme
chez d'autres actuel l'activité physique
le sport est il exactement mais quoi
pourquoi pas après tout est c'est bien
quand même de prévenir un petit peu
avant d'aller tous et à la salle
est vide a aussi des gens qui atteignent
l'orgasme en se retenant de faire pipi
ça s'appelle le pig asthme bon là faut
faire attention parce que se retenir de
faire pipi trop longtemps ça abîme la
vessie on en a déjà parlé de ce passé où
soudain mais bref vous voyez c'est un
phénomène complexe avec une dimension
psychologique qui fait que d'un individu
à l'autre et même d'une fois à l'autre
chez un même individu c'est pas
forcément les mêmes choses qu'il
déclenche et attendez c'est pas tout on
peut littéralement prendre son pied pour
continuer dans la série des orgasmes
insolite le journal de la médecine
sexuelle oui ça existe a décrit le cas
d'une femme de 55 ans qui avait des
orgasmes par stimulation du pied gauche
ce qui n'est pas du tout agréable
puisque ça lui est arrivé plusieurs fois
par jour sans qu'elle ait rien demandé
donc par définition à des moments
parfois pas du tout adéquat
les médecins ont découvert que la
patiente avait été dans le coma à cause
d'une grosse infection qu'elle avait été
hospitalisée en soins intensifs pour
soigner ça et que c'est depuis ce moment
là que les troubles étaient apparues et
ils ont fini par déduire qu'il y avait
une sorte de remaniements au niveau des
terminaisons nerveuses qui apporte les
informations de son pied et de celles
qui sont chargés de ses organes génitaux
et que comme elle se connecte à la
moelle épinière à peu près au même
endroit le cerveau a fini par
interpréter les informations qui
viennent du pied comme des informations
qui venait d organes génitaux et que ça
a déclenché des engagements l'orgasme
c'est de la drogue bon là on a parlé de
cas un petit peu exceptionnel mais faut
savoir que pour le commun des mortels
entre le début d'un rapport sexuel et
l'orgasme le corps libère tout un tas de
substances chimiques qui ont des effets
plus agréable les unes que les autres ça
commence avec l'ocytocine qu'on appelle
aussi l'hormone de l'amour ou l'hormone
de l'attachement même si bon si on veut
être précis c'est un neuropeptides et
puis l'amour tout de suite les grands
mots l'ocytocine elle peut être boosté
par des drogues comme la mdm a par
exemple mais aussi par le désir et pour
bien préparer terra elle a plusieurs
effets dont deux en particulier elle
donne une sensation de bien-être et elle
fait baisser le stress et on va voir que
c'est important ensuite il ya la lully
behring est mignon ça fait un peu
libellules
bon en vrai c'est juste une bonne à
d'autres philippe au film mais bref
c'est une neuro hormones et son champ
d'action c'est le désir c'est elle qui
pose les bases celles qui installe les
tréteaux qui voulait à l'an passé à
table il ya aussi la testostérone qui
fabriqué par les testicules et par les
ovaires et qui est chargé de faire
monter le désir sexuel puis il ya la
dopamine dont on a déjà parlé ici et qui
joue un rôle important dans ce qu'on
appelle le circuit de la récompense en
gros c'est ce qui nous donne du plaisir
et qui nous donne envie de recommencer
puis il ya les ans dans ce film qui sont
libérés à la fin exactement comme après
un exercice physique je schématise 1 et
puis il y en a d'autres en plus mais
déjà le résultat de ce joyeux mélange
elle mêle ça a des effets antalgiques ça
diminue les douleurs anxiolytiques ça
fait baisser le stress et l'anxiété
antidépresseurs ça a des effets
bénéfiques sur le moral et l'humeur de
face temporaire sinon ça se saurait mais
aussi d'autres effets comme un
relâchement musculaire une sensation
d'euphorie et un sentiment de plénitude
qui favorise l'endormissement et le
sommeil et ça accélère la fréquence
cardiaque donc après un orgasme vous
avez pris des chocs de toutes ces
substances gratuite légal et sans effets
secondaires
enfin
l'orgasme ça peut le faire mais
attention on parle bien de l'orgasme pas
du rapport sexuel qui peut aussi faire
mal pour plein de raisons on l'a vu
l'orgasme ça se finit toujours par des
muscles qui se contracte de façon
répétée et ça peut parfois être très
puissant du coup assez rapidement après
ça peut être douloureux soit au niveau
des muscles comme une espèce de crainte
ou de contracture au niveau du bas
ventre soit au niveau des organes les
ovaires le vagin l'utérus etc ça peut
être un signe d'endométriose ça peut
aussi être une autre origine
complètement inconnu mais dans tous les
cas ça vaut le coup de consulter pour en
avoir le coeur net je vous épargne les
trucs genre les céphalées orgasmique le
fait d'avoir mal à la tête après un
orgasme ou la rétinopathie de val salva
posco et talent qui fait perdre la vue
l'espace de quelques instants dans l'es1
conditions dans les deux cas c'est pas
grave je vous en parle juste pour que
vous paniquez pas trop si ça vous arrive
même si je pense que vous allez quand le
panier à et un autre truc aussi
l'orgasme ça peut rendre triste se
sentir vulnérable à fleur de peau triste
voire carrément pleurer après un rapport
sexuel ça arrive et c'est même
relativement fréquents ça s'appelle la
dysphorie post coït halles et à vrai
dire ça arrive même après un rapport
sexuel sans orgasme mais je vous le dise
quand même c'est lié à plusieurs causes
à la fois psychologiques et hormonales
mais on peut dire que c'est à la fois
une grosse décharge émotionnelle est
quelque chose qui ressemble pas mal à
une descente après une prise de drogue
en gros le corps et l'esprit ont été
saturés de substance et de sensations
hyper agréable et tout d'un coup plus
rien le bad ça peut arriver à tout le
monde sans distinction bien sûr si c'est
gênant ça mérite qu'on s'en occupe mais
en soi
pire ennemi de l'orgasme c'est le stress
enfin des substances qu'on produit quand
on est stressé comme l'adrénaline par
exemple leur rôle c'est de préparer le
corps à se battre ou à s'enfuir face à
la cause du stress et elles vont venir
contrer les effets des autres substances
qu'on avait bien un produit pour bien se
préparer à un tout autre type d'activité
du coup ce qui devait gonfler bas ça
gonfle pas donc ça dégonfle les messages
nerveux y passe moins bien et je vous
parle même pas des bonnes dispositions
psychologiques qui sont complètement
ruiné donc par redon le meilleur ami de
l'orgasme c'est le lâcher prise et pour
être capable de lâcher prise on a besoin
de deux ou trois trucs importants la
tranquillité d'esprit déjà c'est à dire
être dans des bonnes conditions genre
pas avoir peur de se faire surprendre
par exemple conçois qu'on soit solo ou
qu'on soit plusieurs mais aussi être en
accord avec ce qu'on est en train de
faire et ça il ya plein de choses qui
peuvent faire que ce soit pas le cas des
principes moraux par exemple parce que
pendant des siècles l'orgasme ça a été
un pur ça a été honteux il peut y avoir
des restes surtout en fonction de notre
éducation ou une pression qu'on se met à
soi même en terme de performance alors
qu'on est d'accord c'est pas le viol ou
plein d'autres trucs qui peuvent venir
parasiter votre esprit est le moment que
vous êtes en train de passer mais le
plus important la condition sinequanone
pour arriver à lâcher prise et donc se
donner toutes les chances d'avoir un
orgasme c'est la confiance la confiance
en la personne avec qui on est la
confiance dans le fait qu'on a la
possibilité de proposer sans être jugé
qu'on a la possibilité de refuser ce
qu'on nous propose qu'on a la
possibilité de changer d'avis en cours
de route le consentement en fait de
toute façon la base de tout et qui n'est
pas négociable donc confiance en soi
plus confiance en l'autre nous rend les
autres sur les cas plus confiance dans
le fait que tout va bien se passer égale
lâcher prise égale orgasme ou pas
d'ailleurs disons que c'est les
meilleures conditions mais l'orgasme
automatique et oui attention l'orgasme
c'est hyper cool pour toutes les raisons
qu'on vient de donner donc ça vaut la
peine de chercher à en avoir et chercher
à en donner mais c'est pas une
obligation non plus je ne reviens pas
d'injonctions à avoir un orgasme à tout
prix et surtout on peut avoir une
sexualité sans avoir d'orgasme y'a pas à
culpabiliser ni à cogiter il ya plein de
raisons qui font qu'on n'arrive pas
forcément toujours à l'orgasme la
fatigue des médicaments l'alcool plein
de trucs et puis le stress dont on a
déjà parlé notamment le stress de ne pas
arriver à jouir précisément le serpent
qui se mord donc qu'il n'y a pas de
pression à se coller c'est des choses
qui arrivent et si votre partenaire se
pose des questions eh ben il faut en
parler d'ailleurs globalement la
communication c'est comme la confiance
et le consentement c'est les piliers il
ya aussi des personnes chez fille
l'absence d'orgasme elle est totale et
elle dure dans le temps on appelle ça la
north gasmi et là encore il ya plein de
causes possibles mais pour vous en citer
juste une des sexologues américain
virginia johnson et william masters ont
mis très tôt en évidence ce qu'on
appelle le syndrome du spectateur en
gros c'est quand les zones de votre
cerveau qui prennent le contrôle pendant
un rapport sexuel vous pousse à analyser
ce qui est en train de se passer plutôt
que de le vivre c'est à la fois une
façon d'être dans l'hyper contrôle est
la conséquence d'angoissé liée aux
performances par exemple on en a déjà
parlé ou à des complexes ou à des doutes
et cette situation qui fait qu'on est
plus spectateur qu'acteur ça inhibe
complètement les mécanismes de leur
agacement d'où l'importance de lâcher
prise et de vivre le moment présent
alors on est d'accord c'est pas toujours
si facile que ça de lâcher prise mais il
ya des moyens d'y arriver et surtout en
attendant d'y arriver l'important c'est
d'être en accord avec sa sexualité y
compris avec le fait éventuellement de
ne pas avoir d'orgasmes ou pas à chaque
fois il faut être en accord avec la voix
est en accord avec soi-même il faut être
en accord avec ses partenaires
évidemment en parler comme on la lit et
puis si vraiment c'est gênant bas il
faut consulter mais en tout cas la
police de l'orgasme va pas venir vous
arrêter si vous n'avez pas joué et
d'ailleurs orgasme venir plaisir on peut
prendre beaucoup de plaisir sans arriver
jusqu'à l'orgasme ce qui compte c'est
pas l'arrivée c'est la quête comme dit
le poète
même si pour l'arrivée c'est cool aussi
il y à point de chemin vers le bonheur
le bonheur c'est le chemin
ça c'est de la haute ce c'est un autre
fait longtemps qu'il n'a pas sorti
d'album donc si on a pas d'orgasme on
peut quand même prendre beaucoup de
plaisir et puis on peut aussi en donner
si on n'est pas tout seul et là c'est
pareil donner du plaisir avec orgasme ou
pas l'important au bout du compte c'est
que tout le monde soit raccord et que
tout le monde soit satisfait et le seul
moyen de savoir si l'autre est satisfait
c'est de lui demander bah quoi après un
dîner vous demandez bien ça va c'était
bon t'as bien aimé quand on a eu assez
et en veut encore bel appareil en fait
alors tant qu'on y est dans les
histoires de plaisir et orgasme c'est
vrai que la plupart du temps l'orgasme
et l'éjaculation ça arrive à peu près en
même temps mais ça veut pas dire c'est
la même chose il peut y avoir des
évacuations mécanique sans orgasme et
al'inverse il peut y avoir des orgasmes
sans éjaculation on appelle ça des
orgasmes sec par stimulation de la
prostate par exemple et pour clôturer le
sujet dans un registre beaucoup plus
grave c'est possible d'avoir un orgasme
pendant un rapport sexuel non consenti
pendant un violent
des études ont démontré que c'est
possible que ça n'est lié à aucune forme
d'excitation ni de plaisir mais juste à
des stimulations mécaniques donc des
réflexes ça pourrait même être un
mécanisme de défense du corps qui
contractent les muscles du vagin pour
empêcher la pénétration ce qui passe
pour un orgasme quelle que soit
l'explication scientifique c'est
possible d'avoir des sensations qui
ressemble à un orgasme pendant un
violent et c'est important d'en parler
parce que ça ne doit pas être un moyen
de discréditer la parole des victimes
l'orgasme c'est bon pour la santé on l'a
vu l'orgasme c'est à la fois un cocktail
de substances qui vous met bien et des
réactions physiques qui elle même une
des conséquences positives
l'augmentation de la fréquence cardiaque
et les contractions musculaires qui ont
même effet qu'une bonne séance de sport
sur la circulation sanguine par exemple
et tous les effets apaisants relaxant
antidépresseurs anxiolytiques etc dont
on a parlé plus tôt et quoi en effet pas
négligeable surtout s'il s'est répété
régulièrement vous trouverez aussi tout
un tas d'études plus ou moins fiables
qui raconte que l'orgasme diminue les
risques de cancer de la prostate ou de
cancer du sein mais le plus important ça
reste le bien-être que ce soit à court
terme ou à long terme les orgasmes c'est
un élément important d'une bonne santé
sexuelle
qui est elle même nécessaire à bonne
santé mentale qui elle-même fait partie
intégrante d'une bonne santé tout court
donc même si attention qu'on a vu qu'on
pouvait très bien vivre sans ce serait
quand même dommage de se priver quand on
a l'occasion surtout pour des raisons
morales qui remonte à une époque où on
n'était pas bien éclairés surtout je
force personne mais au moins maintenant
vous savez tout est en tournée voilà la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien
et surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]